So today I'm gonna make sourdough chicken pot pie
with sourdough biscuits on top.
This is one of my favourite recipes, and my kids normally like it,
but they're going through this phase that absolutely everything I cook,
they just can't stand.
They're always starving to death.
But soon as I cook something,
they just refuse to eat it.
They want to survive off a diet of popsicles and rainbow dust.
That's kids logic for you.
So anyway, I hear I'm starting off chopping up some butter,
I add some flour.
This is a basic biscuit recipe.
I just add some sourdough starter into it,
and then it sits here and rest for a little bit
on the kitchen counter.
Later on, I cook some frozen chicken tenderloins, because why not?
So I had this bright idea to let my daughter help me make dessert,
so maybe she'd be interested in eating it
if I actually had her help me make it.
And that normally works.
This time it was a fail because she distracted me,
and then I ended up
forgetting to put the baking soda in the cinnamon rolls,
so they were absolutely terrible.
While I'm cooking it,
I'm really thinking, like,
what can I cook that actually I like and my kids will actually eat?
And right now it's down to just, like, spaghetti.
Spaghetti Bolognese.
That is it. And I don't even like spaghetti Bolognese.
I'm just eating it out of frustration. Because,
like, if I Cook it.
At least I'll eat. And we don't have to argue at the table. Here.
I'm putting the cream cap in to make this nice and creamy.
This was actually so delicious and the kids just.
I literally had to force feed this to them.
Um, like,
you know, you won't leave the table
and you won't have the disgusting dessert that didn't work out
until you eat some.
This is my favourite part,
cutting out the biscuits.
I normally have my daughter help me with this part,
but I don't know,
she disappeared on the way she went.
At this point,
I was absolutely exhausted
and I didn't really care if the kids ate it or not.
I just wanted to be done.
So I sat down and I enjoyed every little bit of my sourdough biscuit.
Chicken pot pie.